alors mes chers collègues
3 que cette année vous apporte nous
apporte d'ailleurs de nombreuses
satisfactions tant personnel
professionnel je ne doute pas qu'elle
sera riche et chargée pour notre
commission parce que ça démarre déjà un
peu fort et je ne pensais particulière
pour pour
ce d'entre nous qui vont solliciter
cette année le renouvellement de leur
mandat notre front tous mes vœux de
succès alors nous sommes réunis ce matin
en application de l'article L 14 51
terrain du code de la santé publique qui
prévoit l'audition par les commissions
compétentes du Parlement du président
directeurs et directeurs généraux
d'institutions visés à divers articles
du même code
avant leur nomination par l'exécutif
nous entendons ce matin madame marine
chantet candidate proposée aux fonctions
de l'agence de biométrie et je précise
que nous devrons avoir terminé au plus
tard à 10h30 mais ça peut aller plus
vite afin de lui permettre de se livrer
au même exercice devant nos collègues de
la commission des affaires sociales de
l'Assemblée nationale Monsieur Bernard
bonne Monsieur Bernard
puis on fait l'objet d'une d'une
captation vidéo retransmise en direct
sur le site du Sénat avant d'évoquer
l'émission de l'agence biomédecine et le
projet madame chantez je voudrais
rappeler que la vie de vacances pour le
poste de directeur général d'agence de
biomédecine et par où j'en officiel le
12 août 2022 donc ça fait maintenant six
mois la titulaire du post madame
Emmanuel Corto boucher que nous avions
auditionné n'ayant pas sollicité le
renouvellement de son mandat celui-ci a
expiré à la fin du mois d'octobre 2022
et depuis lors le poste est vacant
ce n'est que le 7 décembre 2022 que le
président l'archet était saisi par la
première ministre de cette demande
d'audition je ne peux que regretter les
délais de prise de décision pour
dénominations si importantes pour le bon
fonctionnement de notre système de santé
j'indique à cet égard que la vie de
vacances pour l'Agence nationale de
santé publique santé publique France a
été publié le 27 juillet 2022 que le
poste est lui aussi vacant depuis la fin
octobre sans que nous n'ayons été saisi
à ce jour depuis de demande d'audition
et ce n'est pas comme si nous étions en
Christ sanitaire donc
nous ne pouvons donc nous satisfaire
d'une telle gestion des nominations et
je le ferai savoir la première ministre
mais vous n'en êtes nullement
responsable madame l'Agence de la
biomédecine qui nous occupe ce matin
était créé par la loi de bioéthique du 6
août 2004 c'est un établissement public
administratif placé sous la tutelle du
ministre de la Santé notre assemblée
vous présenter au Conseil d'Orientation
d'agence par nos collègues Bernard
Chaumier et Patricia Schillinger
l'agence et compétente d'un domaine de
la greffe de la reproduction de
l'embryologie de la génétique humaine
ces missions étaient complétées par la
loi bioéthique du 2 au 2021 en matière
de procréation avec l'ouverture de
l'assistance médicale la procréation au
couple de femmes et aux femmes seules le
développement de l'autoconservation des
gamètes et la mise en oeuvre de registre
des donneurs notre commission attendait
d'ailleurs cette nomination afin de
faire le point sur le sujet des gamètes
à la suite de la dernière loi de
bioéthique j'indique également que j'ai
demandé à la Cour des comptes de se
pencher sur les missions de l'Agence de
la biomédecine à la suite des travaux
conduits sur d'autres agences du système
de santé je vous laisse la parole madame
chanter pour présenter votre parcours
que nous connaissons puisque vous avez
été entendu à plusieurs reprises par
notre commission dans le cadre de vos
différentes fonctions et je souhaiterais
que vous nous exposiez les enjeux que
vous identifiez pour l'agence et la
façon dont vous entendez y répondre et
je vous laisse la parole
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs je suis très
honoré d'être auditionné aujourd'hui
pour prendre la direction de l'agence de
la biomécine et j'espère que vous me
donnerez votre confiance j'en profite
évidemment pour vous souhaiter présenter
également tous mes vœux pour cette
nouvelle année et j'espère qu'elle aura
l'occasion de voir l'occasion de nous
revoir dans pour discuter de tous les
enjeux portés par cette agence
extrêmement importante donc
effectivement c'est un établissement
public administratif qui est sous la
tutelle du ministère de la Santé qui a
été créé par la loi du 6 août 2004 donc
dans la suite de l'Établissement
français des greffes qui concerne en
fait quatre grands domaines d'activités
qui ont tous en commun de
requérir l'utilisation de produits
d'éléments du corps humain à des fins
soins médicales soit scientifiques donc
il s'agit évidemment du prélèvement des
greffes et d'organis tissus du
prélèvement de cellules souches
hématomoïdes pour faire des grèves de
moelle osseuse
l'assistance médicale à la procréation
et puis le tout ce qui est diagnostic
prénatal génétique humaine et
embryologie donc avec le travail sur les
cellules souches embryonnaires donc
l'ensemble de ces domaines sont très
largement régis par les dispositions
issues des différents lois de bioéthique
dans la dernière a été promulguée il y a
maintenant 18 mois donc compte tenu des
missions extrêmement techniques et très
sensible qui sont suivies par cette
agence ces équipes possèdent une
expertise multidisciplinaire de très
haut niveau je tiens à la saluer ici
qu'elle soit médicale scientifique
juridique éthique également en termes de
systèmes d'information ce qui est très
important et de gestion des données
et donc c'est une agence qui est très
reconnue à la fois sur le plan national
et international par les professionnels
de santé les chercheurs et également
toutes les associations de patients et
d'usagers
donc c'est également une agence qui
requiert des opérations H24 donc il y a
eu pour assurer la continuité de service
dans le cadre de la qualité de
répartition des greffons donc nécessite
également une organisation logistique
extrêmement pointue sa gouvernance vous
en avez parlé madame la Présidente et
très originale et assez structurée en
lien avec la complexité de ses missions
notamment donc un conseil
d'administration présidé par le
professeur B mais également vous l'avez
dit un conseil d'orientation ou siège
plusieurs parlementaires à la fois des
sénateurs et des et des
députés j'y arrive donc il s'est présidé
par le professeur Guérin et enfin un
comité médical et scientifique avec deux
collèges sur la partie greffe et un
autre sur la partie
embryologie et donc et procréation donc
on voit que c'est une gouvernance qui
est très structurée et qui permet du
coup de suivre l'ensemble des activités
de l'agence alors nous sommes là
actuellement au démarrage d'un nouveau
la troisième révision de la loi de
bioéthique a été votée en août 2021 donc
ces dispositions sont très claires elle
a permis de nombreuses avancées dans le
les domaines notamment de la procréation
médicalement assistée on va en reparler
et aussi beaucoup de clarification de
certains sujets qui n'étaient pas
forcément
encore aussi précis donc qui est
maintenant l'heure est vraiment à la
mise en oeuvre de cette loi et à son
application concrète dans au quotidien
le ministère de la Santé a également
annoncé début 2022 la révision des trois
plans ministériels qui concernent
l'activité de l'agence donc le cadre
également opérationnel et très définie
et enfin nous avons un nouveau Coop un
contrat d'objectivité et de performance
qui est finalisé et qui va être
prochainement signé par le ministre donc
on est vraiment maintenant dans un cadre
stratégique qui est très bien défini et
pour les prochaines années et l'heure et
maintenant à la mise en oeuvre et en
adéquation avec ses orientations en
fonction des moyens qui à louer à
l'agence alors concernant les greffes
d'organes donc la mise en place du
quatrième plomb greffe qui a été
présenté devant cette commission en juin
dernier par Emmanuel cortobushi donc a
pour objectif déjà de relancer
l'activité de greffe qui est évidemment
été très impacté par le covid vous avez
vous savez qu'en 2020 on a vu une chute
de 25% de l'activité de greffe des
transplantations donc c'est quand même
considérable et donc maintenant il
s'agit de relancer les prélèvements
notamment parce que vous savez qu'il n'y
a pas de grève sans prélèvement donc
c'est hors le taux de refus avait
augmenté au moment du covid donc on a un
gros travail pour
retravailler
réexpliquer à l'opinion avoir tout un
travail de sensibilisation et
d'information du public pour
réabaisser et les travaux ont déjà
commencé c'est déjà sur la bonne
direction mais on n'est pas encore
retourné à la situation précovide et
puis il faut aussi qu'on développe le
don du vivant qui est un dont beaucoup
plus méconnu et qui nécessite aussi des
actions de sensibilisation notamment
pour le Rhin et pour le foie pour les
enfants
tout cela passe par une meilleure
déploiement territorial ça c'est une
véritable nouveauté de ce plan greffe
qui est un pari qu'on fait dans un
changement de méthode
qui s'agit en fait maintenant de donner
des objectifs par région donc d'adapter
en fait ces objectifs nationaux aux
spécificités de chaque territoire en
lien avec les ARS et avec les équipes
concernées donc en fonction des
spécificités locales donc ça ce sera un
des rôles de l'agence d'animé ce
déploiement territorial et en lien avec
ses différents
correspondants régionaux qui sont vous
savez extrêmement actifs ça passerait
aussi par la mise en place des
infirmières à pratiques avancées vous
savez que c'est une nouvelle aussi
modalité de vos métiers dans le monde de
la santé qui est une des réponses à la
pénurie de personnel et au manque
d'attractivité qui frappent les hôpitaux
actuellement je pense que ça ne vous a
pas échappé et notamment l'activité de
greffe donc ça permet non seulement
d'améliorer la qualité du processus de
greffe sur l'ensemble du processus que
ce soit pour au moment du recueil du
consentement des proches mais jusqu'à là
au suivi pose greffe mais ça permet
aussi de redonner du temps au médecin
donc il y a un vrai travail alors ça il
faut aussi qu'on mette en place ces
nouveaux métiers qui pour l'instant
n'existe pas qu'il faut organiser en
lien avec le ministère de la Santé et
donc comme je l'ai dit il faudra tout ça
passera évidemment par la promotion du
don qui est une des missions confiée
voilà que la loi a confié à l'agence qui
qui est vraiment un des fondements du
fonctionnement de l'agence et qui pour
agir sur les mentalités donc et
augmenter le taux de prélèvement vous
savez que je vous le rappelle ce plan
greffe c'est une nouveauté aussi
bénéfique pour la première fois d'un
financement dédié qui de 210 millions
d'euros supplémentaires sur les 5 ans
qui soulignent vraiment l'implication du
ministère de la Santé qui a voulu
vraiment les moyens aussi à l'ensemble
des de la filière de pouvoir développer
cette activité concernant les grèves de
moelle osseuse nous sommes aussi leur
sera la mise en place donc du quatrième
plan parce que là aussi il est il est
sorti donc il vise à faciliter l'accès
aux cellules souches hématopoïétiques
donc en proposant toutes les sources de
cellules souches vous savez qu'il y en a
plusieurs qui permet donc de
sélectionner le meilleur greffon en
fonction de la pathologie de l'âge du
stade de la maladie et de l'urgence à
réaliser la grève parce que
malheureusement ça se fait aussi souvent
dans des contextes de pathologies
cancéreuses donc en augmentant le nombre
de donneurs en France vous savez qu'on
n'a pas beaucoup de donneurs de moelle
osseuse on est sur un gros 330 000
donneurs contre 9 millions en Allemagne
donc c'est un vrai différence donc il y
a un vrai sujet de d'augmentation du
nombre de donneurs donc sachant qu'on
s'était donné à un objectif de 20 000
nouveaux donneurs par an on est on a
déjà dépassé cet objectif en 2021 donc
on est déjà à 24000 donneurs en 2021
donc on est sur la bonne pente mais là
aussi ça va passer évidemment sur la
promotion du don et surtout à la divers
des donneurs parce qu'il s'agit de
masculiniser le registre en fait c'est
mieux d'avoir des donneurs hommes parce
que les femmes appris quand elles ont
des grossesses immunises et donc les
qualités de prélèvement sera de moins
bonne qualité à plus à risque pour le
receveur donc il faut plutôt des hommes
et plutôt si possible issus de la
diversité pour permettre d'avoir toutes
les phénotypes les hlables
il s'agit aussi de réduire les délais de
la greffe là aussi on a aussi une
optimisation à faire sur les typages HLA
et donc vous savez que maintenant tout
se fait en ligne on a optimisé le
process avec une inscription les gens
qui veulent donner leur moelle
s'inscrivent en ligne et reçoivent par
la poste un kit de prélèvement salivaire
ce qui leur permet déjà de faire le
typage voilà le plus vite possible et
éviter du temps de d'embouteiller aussi
le système de soins et le qui est
toujours en ce moment évidemment sous
tension
enfin sur la concernant la l'assistance
à la médicale à la procréation qui est
un sujet qui avait beaucoup agité vos
débats il y a en 2021 ce que c'était
donc si vous savez que le secteur a été
mis sous très forte tension suite à la
publication de la loi et l'application
de la loi parce que on a un afflux de
demande qui ont largement dépassé en
fait ce qui avait été anticipé donc il
est problème qu'on avait sous-estimé la
portée société en fait des dispositions
que vous avez votées donc qui permet
d'étendre le bénéfice de l'AMP à des
nouveaux publics donc l'enjeu là ça va
être déjà de d'améliorer de gérer les
délais d'attente pour la MP qui se sont
allongés de fait alors que l'objectif
était de les réduire donc ils étaient
donc vous savez que maintenant le flux
des nouveaux publics sont très largement
majoritaires sur les demandes d'AMP et
notamment des femmes seules donc c'est
un vrai changement sociétal que vous
avez enclenché avec le vote de sa loi et
on ne sait pas encore si cette
augmentation est structurelle ou
conjoncturel avec une forme de
rattrapage donc ça pour l'instant on
regarde les choses de manière
extrêmement précises et suivie et donc
notre objectif c'est de tendre vers
l'auto suffisance nationale sur les dons
de gamètes alors je voudrais vous
rassurer tout de suite sur la partie don
de spermatozoïdes on est plutôt très
satisfait parce que on a doublé on a
vraiment augmenté le nombre de donneurs
récemment donc on est on n'a pas du tout
de problème d'accès aux dons de gamètes
de mal spermatozoïdes par contre sur le
don de vos sites il faut encore qu'on
améliore aussi les choses mais c'est
vrai que les nouveaux publics c'est
surtout des dons de spermatozoïdes donc
on n'a pas de problème normalement pour
répondre à cette demande là en termes de
gamètes mais ça n'empêche qu'il faut
vraiment améliorer l'objectif sur le don
de vos sites et puis ça ajoute à cela
les demandes d'auto-conservation des non
médical qui dont la demande là aussi est
très forte et qui se confirme en 2022
c'est-à-dire que ça a commencé dès 2021
et ça continue de se donc on est
vraiment dans un bouleversement du
fonctionnement de ce secteur et c'est
pour ça que l'agence a mis en place à la
demande du ministère de la Santé un
comité national de suivi qui permet en
fait de donner une démarche assez
inédite suite à de la loi et qui permet
d'avoir un avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes de partager les informations
et aussi de voilà de suivre l'évolution
et d'adapter les choses et notamment le
financement qui a suivi parce que on a
pu vu le nombre de demandes il a fallu
ajuster et le ministère alloué les
moyens nécessaires pour permettre au
secteur de
d'avancer enfin dernier champ d'activité
de l'agence je serai évidemment très
attentive à soutenir toute l'activité de
de des consultations de génétiques qui
est un sujet aussi très important et
notamment des nouvelles techniques de
diagnostic comme le séquençage génomique
à très haut débit et notamment aussi
l'information neutre et rigoureuse du
public concernant tous les tests il
existe proposé à la vente sur Internet
c'est des sujets aussi extrêmement
sensibles sur lequel il faut vraiment
être toujours à la pointe et suivre les
évolutions technologiques et nos
manières plus générale évidemment les
activités de recherche sur l'embryon et
les cellules souches embryonnaires
feront momiseront toute mon attention
alors deux mots maintenant sur mon
parcours même si Madame la présente vous
rappeliez que vous connaissiez
effectivement j'ai déjà eu l'honneur de
venir plusieurs fois dans cette
commission donc je vous savez que je
suis médecin de formation mais j'ai fait
le choix d'une spécialité de santé
publique pour mon intérêt pour les
politiques publiques et aussi pour une
approche multidisciplinaire des
problématiques de santé et donc j'ai
fait une carrière très variée à la fois
en administration centrale territoriale
en cabinet ministériel en établissement
public au sein de l'Inspection générale
des affaires sociales qui m'a permis en
fait de développer en plus de mes
compétences médicales et techniques des
compétences stratégiques administratives
gestionnaire et puis aussi juridique
donc j'ai démarré ma carrière dans le
champ des produits de santé d'abord à ce
qui à l'époque à l'Agence Française des
produits de santé qui maintenant il a
NSM puis à la caisse centrale de la
mutualité sociale agricole toujours sur
le champ du médicament et enfin comme
conseillère du ministre de la Santé à
l'époque Xavier Bertrand sur le chant du
médicament aussi puis j'ai rejoint la
direction de la sécurité sociale donc
pour m'occuper du financement du système
de soins donc sur un champ beaucoup plus
large et notamment la construction et le
suivi de Londres que vous votez chaque
année ici et aussi je m'étais beaucoup
occupée d'expérimentation des nouveaux
modes de rémunération des professeurs de
santé en fait j'ai construit le modèle
économique des maisons de santé qui à
l'époque aussi étaient très soutenue je
me souviens bien au sein de cette maison
j'ai ensuite intégré l'Inspection
générale des affaires sociales donc où
j'ai fait de nombreuses missions dans le
champ évidemment de la Santé Protection
sociale mais aussi j'ai élargi aux
chances sociales avant de prendre la
direction de la branche accident du
travail maladie professionnelle donc
voilà et là vous m'aviez entendu à ce
moment là
depuis 2019 je m'occupe de lutte contre
la pauvreté donc encore un autre champ
du champ social et notamment donc de la
mise en place et de l'ajustement de la
stratégie nationale de lutte contre la
pauvreté dans une approche très
interministérielle et territorialisée
donc qui m'a aussi permis de développer
d'autres d'autres regards cependant je
voulais vous rappeler que les sujets de
biotique m'ont toujours passionné depuis
ça remonte loin mon premier stage
d'externe en 1992 quand j'étais que j'ai
fait dans le service d'immunologie
pédiatrique du professeur Fischer à
Necker où on faisait les premières
grèves de moelle osseuse et donc j'avais
à l'époque après suivi deux maîtrises de
génétique sur la maîtresse de génie
humaine et d'immunologie au moment même
où voter les premières lois de
bioéthique donc vous voyez ça remonte à
quelques temps donc maintenant comme je
vous l'ai dit le cadre stratégique de de
et juridique de des activités d'agence
et désormais très bien posé donc l'enjeu
maintenant ça va être de mettre en 96
orientations je pense que mon expérience
à parfois hospitalière de praticienne
mais aussi celle acquise à la Direction
de la Sécurité sociale ou à l'IGAS sur
des volets plus administratifs
organisationnelles financiers aussi me
seront très utiles en fait pour réussir
cette mission et me permettront de
comprendre aussi les contraintes qui
pèsent actuellement de manière
particulièrement forte sur le
fonctionnement quotidien des équipes et
des établissements hospitaliers qui sont
en charge de ces activités niveau cache
pas que voilà la crise de l'hôpital qui
touche l'hôpital sont actuellement et
m'obligera à être et de toute façon
c'est une de mes je pense de mes
qualités d'être à l'écoute des
professionnels de santé qui sont quand
même le cœur du réacteur ou d'une des
activités de l'agence et j'irai
d'ailleurs je souhaite aller très vite
sur le terrain les rencontrer pour
reprendre contact et voir comment évolue
les choses pour essayer de trouver les
meilleures solutions adaptées alors à ce
contexte quand même très difficile et
comme je vous l'ai dit comme il y a un
gros enjeu de déploiement territorial ça
va être évidemment un enjeu très fort
d'aller
vraiment rencontrer les toutes les
équipes et les coordinations régionales
je ne manquerai pas effectivement de
continuer à associer aussi très
fortement les associations de patients
et d'usagers qui sont les chercheurs les
médias à toutes les activités de
l'agence vous savez que le déploiement
de la démocratie sanitaire et inscrit
dans le team des priorités de l'agence
c'est inscrit d'ailleurs dans le contrat
d'objectifs et de performance qui a été
proposé au ministre donc c'est vraiment
pour moi une condition sinequanone pour
maintenir la confiance entre du public
envers l'agence sur des activités
extrêmement sensibles surtout dans une
période où cette relation de confiance
est particulièrement questionnée et donc
je pense que ce dialogue à la fois
professionnel et citoyen et doit être
vraiment encore plus développé et
j'aurais à cœur de le faire sur sur ce
sujet là je pense l'avoir déjà avoir
déjà cette expérience là dans mes
activités actuelles par exemple sur la
lutte contre la pauvreté où je travaille
de manière extrêmement étroite avec les
associations de lutte contre la pauvreté
ce qui a été très utile je dois le dire
pour gérer la crise covid qui est passée
pour être essayé de trouver ensemble des
solutions concrètes dans une période de
crise qui a été quand même durable
permettant de d'atténuer le choc de
cette crise sur les populations les plus
vulnérables voilà j'aurais évidemment à
coeur donc de m'inscrire dans dans la
continuité des diitrices générales qui
m'ont précédé notamment à une courage
Emmanuel Corto boucher pour qui ont
porté consolider les valeurs de la
vengeance qui sont l'équité
l'impartialité la fiabilité la
transparence aussi et puis les
solidarités bien évidemment et donc au
vu du parcours que je vous ai résumé je
pense que je serai je serai à coeur de
capable d'être de suivre préserver cette
expertise et cette impartialité je vous
remercie de votre attention et je suis
prête à vous répondre à vos questions
c'est alors je vais passer la parole à
Corinne Imbert
qui rapporte la branche maladie ensuite
Laurence Cohen Bernard Chaumier merci
madame la Présidente merci Madame pour
votre exposé et pour votre présentation
même si effectivement vous avez déjà
reçu au sein de cette commission puisque
c'est la période des vœux permettez-moi
de vous présenter tous mes vœux et
présumer vous serez demain directrice de
l'agence donc des vœux de réussite aussi
à la tête de cette agence permettez-moi
de revenir sur à travers différentes
questions sur sur les sujets que vous
avez abordés lors de cette présentation
tout d'abord évidemment une question
peut-être sur la mise en oeuvre de la
loi de bioéthique donc qui vous l'avez
rappelé a été votée il y a 18 mois où en
est-on de sa mise en oeuvre le dernier
rapport du Sénat sur le contrôle de
l'application de la loi déplorer un
certain nombre de lacunes est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire si début 2003 des
2023 pardon des taxes d'applications
restent à prendre
après la loi vaut-il il y a 18 mois
les demandes de d'AMP vous l'avez évoqué
un nombre de demandes en hausse
importante notamment de la part de deux
femmes seules
comment comptez-vous travailler pour
réduire les délais et est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui est-ce qu'aujourd'hui il
y a une priorisation de certains
dossiers au regard en fonction de l'âge
des demandeuses
l'activité greffe de greffe d'organes
évidemment
et vous l'avez également rappelé a été
affectée par les effets de la crise
sanitaire
où en est-on à la fin de l'année 2022
vous avez
fait part de l'objectif qui est de
relancer l'activité grève de promouvoir
le don du vivant etc mais où en est-on à
l'heure où nous parlons et est-ce que
les sommes engagées dans le plan
ministériel pour prélèvement de la grève
d'organe et de tissus pour 2022 2026 et
les mesures prévues par ce plan vous
paraissaient réaliste
adapté et suffisante pour répondre aux
enjeux
concernant les dons volontaires
constatez-vous des conséquences durables
de la crise sanitaire sur les deux
volontaires de de moelle osseuse ou de
vos sites les niveaux de dons sont-ils
comparables à ceux de nos voisins
européens
où on est le développement des deux
autres plans ministériels relatifs
respectivement à la procréation à
l'embryologie et à la génétique humaine
d'une part et au prélèvement et à la
grève de ci-dessous schématopoïétiques
d'autre part
les crédits consacrés alors je passe un
peu du coq à l'âne parce que les sujets
sont pas être trop longue donc je
déroule un certain nombre de questions
mais les crédits consacrés par l'agence
au financement de la recherche semble
diminuer
quelles sont les perspectives et quelles
seront selon vous dans ce contexte vos
priorités en la matière
l'organisation de l'agence a récemment
été revu avec notamment le rapprochement
du pôle Recherche de l'activité de
coopération internationale des
partenariats ont notamment été noués
avec le Sénégal la Moldavie et la et la
Tunisie quand il a porté et quels sont
vos projets à moyen terme en la matière
et enfin deux dernières questions une
question des moyens aussi sur les moyens
des agences sanitaires
ces questions se posent régulièrement et
la mecs présidée par le sénateur René
Paul Savary qui était à mes côtés a
décidé au sein de notre commission d'un
travail de contrôle sur ce point
l'agence a-t-elle les moyens humains et
financiers pour assurer ses missions la
question est simple la réponse est
peut-être plus compliquée et alors que
le nombre d'agences et leur
superposition sont souvent critiquées
dans les bain public comment
concevez-vous la coordination entre
l'agence biométrique et d'autres
établissements et je pense notamment à
l'Établissement français du sang que
nous avons auditionné récemment dans
cette commission je vous remercie
alors Laurence Cohen Bernard jaumur on
va prendre toutes les questions Laurence
Cohen
si madame la Présidente tous mes vœux
également au seuil de cette nouvelle
année
donc
[Musique]
nocturne de mobiliser les infirmiers les
infirmières pour mieux coordonner les
prélèvements à l'hôpital et développer
les prélèvements venant d'honneur
décider ou de donneur
vivant alors j'aimerais savoir sur cet
aspect précis donc avoir quelques
éclaircissements de votre part et la
deuxième le deuxième élément de ma
question c'est sur
l'autoconservation notamment des des
ovocytes pardon et
il est depuis le 1er janvier 2022 il est
possible donc de conserver des gamètes
pour raison non médicales mais si près
de 5000 femmes ont réalisé les premières
démarches et que plus de la moitié ont
débuté ce parcours comme la souligner
Corinne Imbert c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué pour les femmes seules où les
ou les couples de femmes alors c'est
vrai que les délais s'allongent et moi
j'ai comme élément en fonction le centre
aussi il y a une inégalité et par
exemple il est possible d'attendre plus
de trois ans en
Île-de-France et à la Réunion mais dans
certaines autres régions ça peut être
six mois est-ce que vous avez
des éléments précis là-dessus et en tout
cas comment est-ce que vous comptez
réduire ces délais de prise en charge et
permettre donc à toutes les femmes de
rendre ce droit d'avoir ce droit qui
doit être effectivement accessible pour
tout donc voilà c'est des éléments plus
de précision sur des questions qui vous
ont déjà été posées et qui balayaient
très large merci d'avance de vos
réponses madame chantais je vous laisse
répondre déjà parce qu'il y a trois
demandes de questions ensuite
alors concernant la mise en oeuvre de la
loi l'application de la loi donc
effectivement il y a eu un rapport qui
est prévu qui ne vous a pas encore été
transmis mais qui le sera très
prochainement parce que les éléments
sont prêts donc la loi de bioéthique
prévoyait 32 mesures d'applications à
prendre des mesures par ordonnances et
six rapports au Gouvernement au
Parlement donc en fait les actions qui
ont été les textes qui ont été priorisés
concernés vraiment l'AMP parce que
c'était le sujet qui paraissait le plus
important donc les textes ont été pris
et c'est vrai que le le ministère et la
BM ce sont surtout concentrés sur la
mise en place aussi du comité de suivi
et aussi de la mise en place de l'accès
aux origines vous savez qui était un des
éléments phares de de la loi donc on est
donc les décrets pour l'instant sont le
retard a été surtout lié à ça on va dire
mais on est dans les clous on va y a pas
eu de de d'impact de non sorties de
textes qui bloquerait la mise en œuvre
un certain nombre de dispositions il y a
une ordonnance sur les dispositions
outre-mer qui va vous être tranquille
tout conseil d'État et qui va vous être
soumis très prochainement là parce que
l'habilitation pour le l'ordonnance
s'arrête le premier février 2023 donc ça
va être imminent donc là dessus on est
sur donc le sujet ça a été vraiment de
plutôt de prioriser la mise en oeuvre de
la du volley AMP et pour cause comme je
vous l'ai dit il y a eu effectivement
une demande très très importante sur ces
sujets là
justement donc pour enchaîner sur le le
comment on va réduire donc ces délais
donc vous savez donc il y a eu plus de
sur la partie le dernier comité suivi a
eu lieu en octobre 2022 donc ces
résultats sont publiques et partager
avec les différentes parties prenantes
donc on a sur la partie
dont ovocytes qui avait effectivement
beaucoup chuté en 2020 mais qui est bien
maintenant bien remonté en 2021 on a
déjà rattrapé le niveau 2019 donc on est
on était en train déjà arrivé au niveau
de d'avant grise et la tendance continue
en 2022 j'attends les derniers chiffres
parce que tout ils sont en cours de
consolidation mais on est on a aussi
surtout réussi à stabiliser le délai qui
était de ce qu'on était à 22 mois alors
qu'à un moment il y avait une
dégradation de ce délai aussi de de
d'accès à ces dons aussi donc là on est
en phase de on a stabilisé et on est en
train de remonter même si on est encore
je vous l'ai dit c'est un des lieux de
progrès le plus importants sur le sujet
en revanche sur les dons spermatozoïdes
là on est vraiment savait beaucoup alors
encore plus chuter on avait une chute de
60% en 2020 mais le rebond en 2021 a été
très impressionnant parce qu'on a
multiplié par deux le nombre de Nord on
a 600 donneurs versus même plus vers 135
en 2020 et 317 en 2019 donc vous voyez
qu'on est
même fait un bon en avant et donc on un
stock le stock national de paillettes et
donc désormais capable de répondre à
toutes les attentes donc le le
sujet c'est que donc le maintenant c'est
les nouveaux publics qui représentent
maintenant comme je vous l'ai dit 60 %
des 3000 personnes en attente d'une AMP
avec don de sperme donc c'est et
notamment contre ce qui n'était pas
forcément prévu pas plutôt les femmes
seules qui sont elles-mêmes majoritaire
dans les nouveaux publics donc là on est
sur un délai moyen d'une AMP avec don de
ce cas ma 14 mois donc on est un tout
petit peu au dessus de ce qui était
juste avant crise donc on est plutôt
dans une phase de stabilisation et on
espère que 2023 permettra de rentrer
dans une logique plus plus stable
concernant les priorisations des
dossiers il y a eu un arrêté qui a prévu
vraiment les règles de priorisation là
je n'en rentre pas en ligne de compte
c'est vraiment le le la date d'entrée
d'inscription dans le processus qui a
été retenu en termes de bonnes pratiques
et donc qui maintenant fixé par arrêté
pour justement clarifier donc il y a
aussi tout un enjeu de de
d'harmonisation aussi des pratiques des
séquences pour être sûr que ce soit une
égalité aussi d'accès en termes de
priorisation
sur les financements donc est-ce que les
financements donc sur les je vous sur
les dons de volontaires de gamètes je
pense qu'on je vous ai répondu et on a
sans doute encore des choses alors j'ai
pas encore toutes les données de
comparaison par rapport au niveau
européen je pourrais revenir vers vous
pour vous les donner mais je sais que
sur la partie comme je l'ai dit on n'a
pas d'allemand de problèmes pour la
partie spermatozoïde c'est plutôt sur la
partie ovocytes et sur lequel vous savez
que l'importation de gamètes est
interdite donc on est on a vraiment une
vocation aussi à être en auto-suissance
donc ce sur ce sujet là
sur la les greffes donc sur les greffes
on est donc effectivement comme vous
savez donc il y a eu une chute très
importante de 25% en 2020 en 2021 on
avait déjà rebondi à plus 20% donc on
est quasiment revenus au niveau de 2006
vous voyez on est on avait fait quand
même un grand grand retour en arrière
mais c'est surtout maintenant c'est en
train de
c'est en train de remonter encore ce que
les données sont en train d'être
consolidées au sein de l'agence ça fera
l'objet d'une conférence de presse tout
début février juste après ma prise de
fonction donc je devais voilà je n'ai
pas encore ce qu'ils sont en train de
travailler mais les données sont plutôt
en attendant encore un ou deux centres
mais donner sont plutôt rassurantes sur
2022 on va être dans l'intervalle cible
qui avait été fixé donc ça c'est plutôt
ça montre bien aussi et je tiens à le
saluer ici la la résilience du système
de soins c'est-à-dire qu'il s'est quand
même mobiliser malgré les tensions
hospitalières malgré les difficultés on
est vraiment dans un moment où
l'activité essaye de se remettre en
oeuvre pour parler justement dans le
cadre de des grèves sur les IPA donc
actuellement ça nécessite les textes ne
sont pas encore pris il faut qu'il soit
travailler au sein du ministère de la
santé c'est vous savez le problème c'est
que maintenant ça a beaucoup de succès
les IPA je m'en réjouis parce que c'est
des professions que j'ai portées il y a
20 ans j'ai eu beaucoup travaillé à
l'époque sont appelés à délégation de
tâches il y a toujours donc je trouve
que c'est intéressant de voir que
maintenant ça devient tout le monde tout
le monde veut des effets dans toutes les
données mais évidemment il faut aussi
qu'on régule les choses parce que vous
avez bien compris que les infirmières ne
sont pas non plus en excès dans notre
système de soins actuellement mais c'est
sûrement une manière aussi de d'atterrir
d'être plus attractif pour ces publics
là donc c'est quelque chose qui est très
porté par l'agence je sais que c'est
porté également par le ministère l'enjeu
ça va être de trouver le le bon niveau
de définition du référentiel métier
c'est-à-dire qu'il faut pas faire non
plus que c'est vrai que l'activité de
greffe est une activité extrêmement
inactivité de niche donc soit on fait un
métier spécifique sur ça soit on fait
qui est plus large peut-être on
estphrologie ou enfin voilà il faut
trouver quelque chose qui permette aussi
aux personnes qui vont se spécialiser
dans ce domaine là sachant qu'il y a
déjà des infirmières qui sont déjà dans
une logique très spécialisée mais
d'avoir aussi après une fois qu'elles
ont un diplôme qui lui permet d'avoir un
parcours plus diversifié donc
ça ça va être un enjeu du premier enfin
voilà de l'année 2023 sachant
qu'actuellement je vous cache pas que le
ministère est un peu en ébullition avec
tous les annonces qui ont été faites sur
la réforme du système de soins donc on
va essayer de répondre à
à
voilà en plus la réforme du ministère
comme un interne ce qui est voilà c'est
vrai que c'est mais en tout cas j'ai
déjà pris contact avec la direction
générale d'organisation des soins pour
ces sujets là parce que donc et je sais
qu'ils y travaillent
concernant
les les crédits de recherche alors je
n'ai pas la réponse sur la est-ce qu'il
y a ils auraient baissé ça je ne veux
pas dire de bêtises parce que je n'ai
pas eu de contact encore avec le
Ministère de la Recherche là-dessus je
vérifierai de votre côté mais
effectivement je pense que c'est quand
même un sujet je n'ai pas eu en tout cas
on ne m'a pas signalé de baisse de
crédit d'alerte sur ce sujet là donc
c'est un premier élément de réponse mais
effectivement je pense qu'on a un gros
travail au niveau international vous
savez que l'agence c'est quand même un
petit peu faire de long enfin de
beaucoup d'activités au niveau de ses
activités au niveau à la fois européen
et au niveau international on est en
train de travailler vous savez la lettre
sans labellisés au ms aussi donc il y a
dans la logique de favoriser aussi le
rayonnement de l'agence
de faire connaître son savoir-faire et
aller former aussi d'autres équipes à
l'étranger donc je ça c'est une des
priorités de également inscrit dans le
coq donc ce sera très intéressant parce
que ça permet aussi de d'échanger sur
des pratiques aussi et de décès
d'harmoniser les nos même s'il y a des
logiques éthiques très différentes selon
certains pays on est quand même ça c'est
des choix après sociétaux de chacune des
assemblées des lois qui régissent
l'Union européenne mais il y a des
choses intéressantes en termes de
coopération et de convergence sur
certains sujets éthiques
concernant le la coordination entre les
moyens de fonctionnement de l'agence et
la coordination avec les autres les
autres agences sanitaires donc je j'ai
vu que honnêtement c'est une agence qui
a été qui a vu ses moyens augmenter au
moment de la mise en place de la loi
donc c'est assez rare dans la fonction
publique donc on est je pense que les
postes ont été déjà
les personnes ont été recrutés donc je
pense qu'il y avait eu un moment un
moyen une inquiétude sur le financement
de l'agence ça a été corrigé et
justement ce sera l'enjeu du code qui
est signé et donc qui vérifie et qui
consolide les moyens de l'agence dans la
logique la perspective de mettre en
place cette loi de bioéthique bien sûr
on sera vigilant et c'est tout l'intérêt
aussi parce qu'il y a les moyens de
l'agence en tant qu'elles puis après il
est moyen de l'ensemble des activités de
la filière donc c'est aussi l'occasion
ces comité de suivi qui existent sur à
la fois sur la partie MP et aussi le
suivi du plan greffe permettra aussi de
vérifier si on est en possibilité de
répondre à toutes les missions qui ont
été confiées et comme l'agence est suivi
est chargée de la mise en oeuvre
opérationnelle du plan je pense qu'elle
sera aussi assez vigilante à défendre
ses moyens et quand la coordination
entre les agences entre le FS bon je
sais que c'était un sujet récurrent mais
c'est des activités quand même très
différentes même si ça peut paraître
proche il y a bien sûr en commun le don
et donc ça c'est sur les aspects
étiquets juridiques mais après c'est le
FS c'est aussi une agence de production
de produits dérivés du sens qui est
quand même pour avoir travaillé un peu
sur le champ du médicament pas avant qui
est soumis à des contraintes qui n'ont
rien à voir enfin c'est pas exactement
le même type d'activité qu'un équilibre
pilotage d'organisation parce que là je
l'ABM est plus dans une logique très
opérationnelle de de d'organisation de
des activités de greffe et
d'autorisation des recherches mais doit
la sur une logique plus plus au dessus
et à la fois très terrain et pas de
production de produits sanguins en tant
que tel donc je pense qu'il y aura pas
de je connais bien les gens qui
travaillent à la FF je pense qu'il y
aura pas de sujets de s'il faut
s'organiser et s'harmoniser sur des
pratiques de dons il y aura pas de sujet
mais on est quand même sur des champs
très identifiés et assez séparés
je crois que je n'ai pas oublié je suis
en train de regarder sur les à ce stade
dites moi si j'avais oublié un point
alors les délais d'attente donc ça c'est
tout l'intérêt aussi du comité de suivi
qui est mis en place parce que qui va
qui regarde aussi des données qui fait
remonter les données région Paris Région
donc on a à coeur aussi d'identifier
effectivement ces inégalités et de voir
après s'il y a des sujets comme on a une
comme je l'ai dit un ajustement des
financement de permettant ces activités
cessantes donc l'objectif c'est d'aller
après vérifier
et équilibrer les différents moyens
allouer au centre qui sont un petit peu
en retard sur le voilà sur le sujet donc
ça moi c'est vrai que j'ai une
expérience pour le coup de pilotage de
réseau vous savez quand j'étais à
l'assurance maladie on gère des réseaux
de caisse on a l'habitude déjà de
j'avais tout un outil de on va mettre en
place voilà des indicateurs de suivi de
pilotage qui sont qui permettent en fait
sont méconnaître les difficultés parce
qu'il faut pas non plus faut faire
attention il y a des aussi des centres
qui ont aussi des problèmes intrinsèques
qui ne sait pas qui ne veulent pas faire
c'est qu'ils ne peuvent pas faire pour
plein de raisons donc de personnel
ou autre mais on peut mettre en place
cette transparence aussi pour essayer de
faire partager les bonnes pratiques
entre centre et être dans une logique de
proactive et de d'émulation plus que de
voilà de mise à l'index il faut faire
toujours très attention surtout je
rappelle dans une période où le système
étant sur tension
et Oliviero merci
merci madame la Présidente merci Madame
la bientôt directrice j'espère pour vous
c'est ce que je vous souhaite pour cette
année en tout cas de vos propos juste
enfin des compléments à ce qui était aux
questions qui ont été posées d'abord
pour dire que
je trouve que la participation au
Conseil d'orientation et je pense que
Catherine de roche me démentira pas elle
en a l'expérience et vraiment très
intéressantes sous dans la première
partie après en général je reste pas aux
séances quand on rêve les dossiers
techniques mais les deux préhenseurs
sont beaucoup consacrés à des échanges
généraux point d'actualité et ce qui est
très marquant et ça n'est pas très
étonnant vous en avez largement parlé
mais depuis quelques séances c'est
l'application la loi de bioéthique qui
utilise des débats avec beaucoup de
remontées un des grands intérêts de ce
conseil d'orientation c'est qu'il y a
les praticiens on va dire de la chose
qui sont autour de la table et dans
toutes leurs différentes dimensions
d'ailleurs et il y a beaucoup de
remontées quand même de difficultés dans
l'application la loi qui sont retournés
vers le législateur évidemment qu'elle
nous les parlementaires présents nous ne
sommes pas parfois nous sommes en
capacité de répondre parce que le texte
votait quand même avec l'air et parfois
nous avons il est resté une marge
d'appréciation qui relève de textes
réglementaires et qui reste incisés et
bon
le premier point enfin l'AMP est une
source effectivement d'applications à la
loi de difficulté
constante et d'ailleurs il y a un point
qui est saillant vous n'avez pas répondu
comme tous les candidats à ce type de
fonction je tiens à vous le dire à une
des questions de Corinne Imbert c'est à
dire avez-vous les moyens de votre
mission les candidats ne répondent
jamais c'est normal mais pour ce qui est
de la MP les équipes sont très claires
c'est non et c'est une des raisons aussi
du retard on aurait pu penser que il y
aurait une difficulté sur les gamètes
mal comme vous l'avez dit en fait il y
en a pas sur les gamètes
mais c'est plus compliqué effectivement
mais il y a aussi une problématique de
moyens qui est évidente il y a une
problématique de bornes d'âge qu'on
avait parfaitement identifié au moment
du vote de la loi alors les bornes d'âge
supérieures c'est relativement simple
elles ont été précisées reprécisées par
décret je crois un mois à peu près après
l'entrée en vigueur de la loi je si je
me trompe pas au mois de septembre
octobre que le décret était la bande
d'âge minimale comme vous le savez nous
avons décidé le Parlement de ne pas en
fixer et c'est un souci on va c'est ce
que nous disent les équipes moi je
rapporte ici à mes collègues
parce qu'en fait des femmes très seules
vous l'avez noté très jeune vienne faire
une demande d'AMP et évidemment le texte
l'arrêté ne pouvait pas fixer une
priorisation alors que le législateur ne
fixait pas de bandage minimal
est-ce qu'on peut rester dans la
situation actuelle est-ce qu'on doit
trouver une voie d'amélioration c'est
quand même la demande moi je l'ai
entendu et de façon parfois très vive
des équipes qui disent vous nous mettez
dans une situation impossible quand on a
une femme très jeune qui vient et qui
nous fait une demande à MP parce que
voilà donc je comment voyez-vous
l'évolution du travail sur cette
question et d'ailleurs de façon plus
générale
l'échange entre le législateur et
l'Agence de biomédecine me paraît
important le conseil d'orientation n'en
n'est qu'un des éléments très très très
très très ponctuel très fragmentaire il
y a les rapports que vous avez souligné
mais est-ce que vous voyez une méthode
pour on va dire
faire un point et améliorer on va dire
la compréhension de la loi par
les praticiens qui doivent la mettre en
œuvre les équipes et à l'inverse de
retour vers le législateur des
précisions ou des modifications au
regard de l'expérience apporter par la
loi j'ai juste pour pas être long je
vais juste ajouter une question parce
que beaucoup de thèmes ont été débattus
mais sur un thème qui n'a pas été
soulevé jusqu'ici
l'agence de biométrie a été confronté à
de multiples contentieux ces dernières
années qui avait pour but de freiner ses
activités de recherche notamment sur les
cellules souches embryonnaires et un des
multiples objectifs de la loi a été de
fournir on va dire une sécurisation
juridique supplémentaire à l'agence et
de freiner ce contentieux est-ce que
est-ce que vous pouvez tirer un premier
bilan la matière est-ce que le
dispositif a été opté a été efficace
pour faire baisser ce contentieux et
éviter les pertes de temps et d'énergie
à l'agence voilà
Olivier Hainaut
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
pour vos propos et à mon tour vous
souhaitez tout
les meilleurs vœux pour cette nouvelle
année vous nous avez rassuré sur la
question du don de gamètes moi j'avais
une vraie crainte à la suite du droit
d'accès aux origines d'une chute bon
visiblement
ça n'est pas le cas mais
mon interrogation est et la suivante
comment vous voyez la perspective de de
monter en charge de de des demandes
d'AMP parce que je pense que c'est une
une demande forte dans la société je ne
pense pas que ça va s'arrêter alors on
peut avoir un jugement on peut s'en
étonner on peut faire toutes les sous
toute ce genre de raisonnement mais je
pense que c'est une une réalité et et
qu'elle adaptation par rapport à notre
modèle qui est qui est basé sur la
gratuité du don et sur détruisme comment
vous voyez les choses dans une
perspective et puis peut-être est-ce que
vous avez des chiffres sur le nombre de
personnes qui et là c'est légal
vont en Europe pour une AMP
Europe parce que sans doute qu'il doit y
avoir des personnes qui vont faire une
amp or Europe et est-ce que vous avez
aussi des des chiffres précis sur les
évolutions de de de GPA dans d'autres
pays que la France évidemment puisque
ici ça n'est pas autorisé ce que vous
avez des chiffres et des évolutions sur
ces questions qui évidemment sont
essentiels je vous remercie
je laisse répondre avant je voulais
partager en effet ce qui a dit Bernard
jolie le conseil d'orientation de
l'Agence de biomédecine moi j'y suis
allé il y a quelques années vraiment
c'est des matinées passionnantes avec
des sujets là ça l'air plus centré sur
la dernière loi mais vraiment moi j'y
prenais un intérêt à l'époque chez élève
avec notre collègue
il Gilbert Barbier voilà Gilbert Barbie
c'était vraiment des moments
passionnants et ça et aussi est-ce que
moi aussi j'étais surprise de qui est
pas eu des parce que c'était souvent une
des critiques sur le la levée de la
possibilité d'accès aux origines de
lever de l'anonymat laquelle j'étais
pour ma part très favorable
donc de
qui est pas finalement cette se
décrochage des dents de gamètes de
spermatozoïdes en revanche si sans doute
trop tôt pour voir s'il y a des parce
que ce qu'on nous disait c'est souvent
le profil du donneur changeait dans les
pays qui étaient arrivés à cette à cette
levée de l'anonymat mais c'est sans
doute trop tôt peut-être pour qu'on ait
les chiffres et les études sur les
différents profils je vous laisserai pas
merci
beaucoup de questions alors
effectivement je vais pas vous donner
mon avis personnel sur la question c'est
sujet tellement compliqué qui qu'il y
aura pas forcément voilà je pense pas
que ce soit mon avis personnel qui vous
intéresse plutôt je pense que sous ces
sujets et vous l'avez dit Monsieur
geomier c'est ça pose quand même
beaucoup d'interrogations on voit que
vous n'êtes pas le premier à me faire
par des interrogations des praticiens
sur ces réactions face à à la mise en
oeuvre de de ces nouvelles dispositions
et notamment le fait qu'ils sont
confrontés soit des gens jeunes et aussi
beaucoup à de gens qui ne sont pas
malades entre guillemets voilà et donc
c'était un changement de paradigme assez
fort par rapport à leur activité de
soins et effectivement on voit qu'il y a
des réticences des résistances des
interrogations qui sont légitimes
d'ailleurs parce que voilà c'est des
questions de société qui ne sont pas
simples dire je crois qu'elles ont fait
quand même beaucoup de débats au sein de
ces assemblées donc elles font aussi
beaucoup débats au des communautés
médicales et scientifiques et au sein de
la société donc on ne peut pas les
résoudre
voilà juste en disant c'est fini et la
loi a été votée de Gia il y a un cadre
réglementaire donc il faut quand même
expliquer ce cadre réglementaire et je
pense que l'agence son rôle ça va être
effectivement de de créer des travaux de
discussion avec les centres ça c'est
vraiment notamment en termes de bonne
pratique parce que c'est son sa mission
également pour essayer de à la fois
d'écouter ces remontées qui ont leur
réalité leur vérité et d'essayer de
faire coïncider ça avec aussi les
demandes des associations de patients et
d'usagers qui sont qui ont aussi une
autre réalité et qui sont tout aussi
respectables et je pense qu'il faut
qu'on peut très bien lancer des travaux
des groupes de travail un peu sur ces
sujets là pour aussi
des dramatiser au moins expliciter déjà
rien que de en parler des choses sont
souvent
ça permet de clarifier aussi les
problèmes
cette limite d'âge minimale vous n'êtes
pas le premier en parler effectivement
et c'est de toute façon ce sera pas
l'agence qu'il décidera tout seul mais
par contre elle peut préparer des
modifications éventuelles à venir
législatives ou réglementaire et donc on
peut très bien lancer à l'aune de une
fois que les choses vont être un peu
plus stabilisées maintenant que les si
on voit que ça ça continue et que c'est
une tendance qui devient ce qui devient
faut quantifier la réalité enfin
commencer toujours par objectiver le
sujet avant de le de pour mieux le
qualifier et puis après voir qu'est-ce
qu'on peut proposer comme évolution de
pratique et des évolutions
réglementaires et soumettre ça au débat
démocratique donc effectivement je pense
que c'est un sujet qui qui interpelle
enfin je je je maintiens effectivement
beaucoup de débats sur sur le sujet
sur le le les recherches sur l'embryon
on n'a pas
j'ai pas encore vu vous savez que le
temps de la justice est un petit peu
plus long que ça fait que 18 mois que la
loi était
promulguée on n'a pas encore vu de
d'effet
pas des faits significatifs que je peux
vous dire est-ce que ça a freiné ou pas
je pense qu'il faut se donner un temps
un tout petit peu plus long pour
observer la est-ce que les choses sont
stables mais je sais qu'effectivement
l'activité est contentieuse continue
quand même enfin ce n'est pas je sais
qu'il y a eu des phrcs qui ont été voilà
qui font l'objet de de
contentieux donc il faut déjà voir un
peu quelle suite en sont donnés parce
que c'est aussi voilà ça peut aussi les
débats peuvent aussi éclairer les juges
donc il faut laisser un tout petit peu
le temps que les choses se stabilisent
mais et ne pas se précipiter là-dessus
mais pour l'instant je peux pas vous
affirmer avec certitude que ça a
vraiment réduit tous les content sur les
ceci dit les contentieux permettent
aussi de clarifier certains dispositions
enfin c'est il y a aussi des
jurisprudences qui apparaissent et qui
sont c'est pas forcément négatives mais
c'est vrai que c'est un temps qui est un
petit peu long et qui peut retarder des
recherches qui sont absolument
essentiels pour d'autres aspects et
d'autres modèles du soin sur les
chiffres de de la MP alors à l'étranger
on vous savez que maintenant tout ce qui
est les LMP qui sont pris en charge dans
le cadre de la loi au niveau européen
sont pris en charge par l'Assurance
Maladie ça c'est les conventions au sein
de l'Union européenne qui permettent
donc avec des accords très précis qui
permettent cette prise en charge donc ça
c'est suivi par la caisse de Vannes et
c'est dans le cadre du comité de suivi
les chiffres sont très régulièrement
annoncés donc pour l'instant il y a
toujours une activité à l'étranger pour
des problèmes de délai de pour les
personnes notamment qui arrivent en
limite d'âge parce que comme c'est la la
règle qui a été pour l'instant choisi
c'est de l'inscription
la date de l'inscription dans la file
d'attente donc les personnes qui
s'inscrivent tardivement et qui sont
limites d'âge sont conduites à aller à
l'étranger à ma connaissance on ne suit
pas pour l'instant des données il y a
très peu de d'AMP Oreo parce que ce que
j'ai compris c'est que c'est des cas
très particuliers familiaux souvent de
gens qui ont voilà envie de pour des ils
viennent de certaines communautés et ont
besoin de se retrouver près de leur
famille au moment de cette activité là
donc c'est c'est vraiment des cas
particuliers c'est pas du tout quelque
chose de massif et par contre j'ai pas
de données sur les GPA parce que ça
c'est pas des données c'est pas comme
c'est pas autorisé il y a pas de suivi
voilà organisé sur ce sujet là c'est pas
on s'inscrit dans le cadre de la de la
loi donc mais pour l'instant oui il y a
toujours une activité hors
France mais au sein de l'Union pour des
raisons de délai et de limite d'âge qui
ce qu'on peut très bien comprendre en
fait de se donner la chance
avant d'atteindre les limites autorisées
voilà à ce stade très bien ben écoutez
merci beaucoup madame nous vous
souhaitons
total réussite non
dans cette mission
parce que votre nomination est quasiment
acquise d'après ce que je pense et nous
aurons plaisir de vous retrouver parce
qu'on avait organisé cette table ronde
sur les greffes on souhaitait la faire
sur sur le don de le don de gamètes et
mais on attendait qu'il y a une
nomination à la tête de l'agence je
reviendrai avec plaisir
avec grand plaisir je serai vous savez
que j'aime beaucoup
ça permetra aussi de voir les questions
que soulevées notamment Bernard jaumier
sur les difficultés qui rencontrent
voilà merci beaucoup bonne journée à
vous et bonne chance à la haine